Joseph II Persico author of Roosevelt's
secret war FDR and world war ii
espionage when did you get the idea for
this book Brian I was a kid growing up
during the Roosevelt era he's always
been a hero of mine I wondered how I
would be able someday to write a book
about Franklin Roosevelt
I couldn't imagine there was anything
that hadn't been said I pulled up on the
Internet the catalog of the Library of
Congress and I went through it line by
line and there was something like 600
books on Franklin D Roosevelt and I
thought it's it's all said but I've
written a great deal about intelligence
and maybe I could combine the two and
there was nothing in this list of 600
books in the catalog about FDR and
intelligence my my reaction was Joe you
are either brilliant and you've thought
of something that nobody else could
think of or you're a fool and you're
wasting your time because there's no
story so in the end what when did you
start to see a story that had never been
told well I started going down Brian
to Hyde Park to the Roosevelt archives
and that I started virtually from Ground
Zero but as I started plowing through
the papers of George Marshall papers of
Bill Donovan and FDR's papers I realized
there were a lot of months to untold
stories and was very encouraged to
proceed let's pick one of those names
bill Donovan who was he bill Donovan was
a authentic hero of World War one a
Congressional Medal of Honor winner
subsequently a vastly successful Wall
Street lawyer now he becomes in effect
the first head of a Central Intelligence
Agency in the United States Franklin
Roosevelt appoints him in summer of 1941
as what eventually becomes the Office of
Strategic Services kind of a strange
choice because
Donovan was a staunch Republican had run
for governor of New York on an anti
Roosevelt anti New Deal platform but he
was also a man of irrepressible spirit
boundless optimism full of ideas and in
a sense he reflected the qualities of
Franklin Roosevelt so he was named the
head of our first spy service he's you
know they call him Wild Bill Donovan
tell us a wild story well one of the one
of the conclusions I reached about
Donovan was that he was a magnificent
magnet for attracting talent his OSS
attracted college presidents amantu
cysts philosophers writers journalists
photographers actors cameramen Arthur
Goldberg had been a OSS veteran
subsequently goes on the Supreme Court
Office historian Arthur Schlesinger jr.
was with the OSS the French chef Julia
Child was with the OSS but what kind of
struck me about Donovan is the
crack-brained ideas that he could
advance one one of which was that his
agents would somehow intrude into
Hitler's diet substances that would
cause the Fuehrer's breasts to swell his
voice to rise and his moustache to fall
out I did he came forward with was to
drop leaflets over Japanese troops would
show pictures of Japanese women involved
in compromising positions with
Caucasians which presumably would would
demoralize them and seeing that their
women were not being faithful the thing
that was surprising to me is that these
crazy ideas did not turn FDR off at all
he didn't reject them out of hand
because he loved the the surreptitious
the furtive the clandestine and the
covert he's seen your book at I think
the height of the OSS he had something
like sixteen hundred people working for
him more like sixteenth I
16-thousand yes and that's starting from
ground zero
you know we had no intelligence service
to speak of even a year before Pearl
Harbor so kind of relate that to today
the President of the United States has
somebody it was a friend of his who
creates what kind of a and what would
happen if this kind of thing was
developed today well can you relate it
to what's going on in the world right
now I think that the the the real
parallel here is the shocking
unexpectedness of Pearl Harbor and
September 11th how could this happen
that the after the fact the strand of
intelligence that leads from A to B to C
to Pearl Harbor may stand out glaringly
and after the fact the strand of
intelligence that runs from X to Y to Z
to the World Trade Center and the
Pentagon may seem to stand off glaringly
but before the fact this intelligence
doesn't come in single strands it comes
in great bundles you know we were
breaking the Japanese code there were
hundreds of messages available to the
president we now have the NSA which I
understand us something like three
billion dollars of robot wide
eavesdropping so what we have that's
comparable is a a flood tide of
intelligence which seems to overwhelm
the circuitry what we seem to be lacking
is then and now is careful analysis and
analysis to say oh we've got this tide
of intelligence what direction is it
fooling in what did these jigsaw pieces
tell us if we can put them together that
was a failing prior to Pearl Harbor and
obviously a failing now Vincent Astor
what did he do for FDR well I mentioned
a moment ago that the United States
didn't go into the intelligence business
in a serious way until 1941 we were
probably the only world power that
didn't have a professional intelligence
service a Roosevelt relied very heavily
prior to let's say 1940 on a circle of
socialite friends as his sources there
were a group of them who styled himself
the club and they had taken a shabby
apartment on New York's Upper East Side
they had an unlisted phone number they
had a secret mail drop it sounded like
the spy games of boys being carried out
by grown men the chief figure in this
outfit called the club was Vincent Astor
one of the wealthiest men in the country
which one is he in this photo atop
Vincent Astor is the one to the right of
the bar on the ship where he standing or
to the left of FDR let's see that looks
to me like he's - yes yes and and who
was he
Vincent Astor was the the heir of a
massive fortune in the United States he
was that he was a socialite but he was
also a man interested in causes owned
probably the biggest chunks of real
estate in Manhattan he and his other
members of the club while they seemed
like dilettante amateurs had this value
for FDR they were very highly placed for
example Astor was a director of Western
Union and consequently he was privity to
the kinds of cables which were going
from foreign embassies in the United
States back to their homelands and
though it was illegal he had these
cables intercepted and he passed this
intelligence along to FDR another member
of the club was Winthrop Aldrich who at
the time was the head of the Chase
Manhattan Bank Aldrich knew about
international financial dealings he
could report to FDR all the money that
was going into and coming out of the
Russian spy front in the United States
the AM torg trading company but this
this was a pretty unsophisticated level
of intelligence for a country the size
of the United States at that point in
1939 and 40 what kind of an intelligence
gathering operation did FDR have do you
have an official one no he that doesn't
he doesn't begin a formal official
Central Intelligence Agency until the
summer of 1941 what he has before that
are the military services the Office of
Naval Intelligence he has the military
intelligence division of the army and he
has the FBI and he had he tried he's
very unhappy with the lack of
coordination and doesn't that ring a
bell today for example at one point to
try to get these people moving in the
same direction he he calls a meeting of
Hoover's head the FBI the head of
military intelligence and naval
intelligence whoever doesn't deign to
come they said I'm not coming well he
had to be ordered by FDR finally to come
we had the army and navy with the
lunatik handling of the messages that we
were decoding particularly Japanese
diplomatic traffic they had this rivalry
in which the the army would decode
messages on even days we and the Navy
would do it on odd days they had a
system where they would share who got to
deliver the plum traffic to the
president the army would do it in
certain months and subsequent month
would be in the Navy and and it was it
was madness and finally Roosevelt
himself just cut out that nonsense go
back to Vincent Astor was he the one
that went on the trip to try to find
some intelligence over in Japan yeah
again this indicates the rather
amateurish intelligence that Roosevelt
conducted prior to forming a formal
agency and in the OSS Astor had a
magnificent the ocean-going yacht called
the norma hall and had a crew of over 40
members FDR asks Vincent Astor to cruise
the Pacific seemingly on a pleasure
junket and hit places in the Marshall
Islands which were then managed by Japan
as a mandate and to report on our
preparations there and this was great
fun for Vincent Astor and great
adventure he subsequently thought this
would lead
to his becoming FDR's chief of
intelligence but he's up against tougher
rivals and Donovan and some others John
Franklin Carter got a photo of him in
your book who's who easy John Franklin
Carter interesting man was a columnist
in Washington at one point he wrangles
an appointment with the president in the
Oval Office and he in effect says the
FDR
you know I have extraordinary contacts
in journalism among international
government figures among businessmen
worldwide I could easily set up for you
a ring and I would report strictly to
you those about lap that up it was just
the kind of thing that appealed to FDR
off the books circumventing his own
bureaucracy something private
clandestine spy thriller kind of thing
appealed to him so he took money out of
his own white house budget to set up the
John Franklin Carter ring has this money
transferred into the State Department
where presumably it's there to buy
reports about foreign foreign
governments and Carter operates
throughout the war directly reporting to
FDR and the overall how many people are
here at work important very small group
only about 12 but the interesting thing
is that we have an OSS that doesn't
necessarily know about the Jim Franklin
Carter ring we have a John Franklin
Carter who doesn't necessarily know
about the Astor ring and you say that
FDR didn't write very much down FDR
by his character and temperament was
ideally suited for for secret warfare he
loved to trade in secrets he was a
master manipulator of people he misled
his own associates when it suited him he
seemed to enjoy subterfuge for its own
sake and he said it best himself he said
I'm a juggler I never let my left
you know what my right hand is doing and
to answer your point he left virtually
no fingerprints one of the most
frustrating things that historians on
the trail of Franklin Roosevelt complain
about is the lack of written commitment
to decisions that he made or
explanations as to what he did what did
you learn about him
but as a person well I always had had a
sense that that Roosevelt was a man with
a certain amount of guile my research in
writing Roosevelt's secret war convinced
me even further of as I said a moment
ago he was ideally suited for this kind
of thing he he was I think some of the
best descriptions of him which I accept
as is essential to his character one of
which was made by one of his New Deal
associates who said the man always
conceals the purposes of his mind and
another one of his close associates said
I this was Robert Sherwood who wrote
speeches for wolves but he said I could
never penetrate that heavily forested
interior Henry Wallace said the only
certainty in the Roosevelt
administration was what was going on
inside FDR's head my initial expectation
that he would be a man who held the
cards close to the vest was confirmed
somebody said to me out well did this
make you think less of him
it made him more interesting to me a
more textured character you say in the
book that your colon Powell helped you
with information on this book and I
misinterpret that or was that welcome
your old friendship in this sense as you
know I was a : pause collaborator on his
autobiography my American Journey Colin
Powell needless to say had very very
useful connections throughout the
federal bureaucracy and what I would
have queries I could go to some of his
staff with who would get answers for me
for which I'm very grateful how long did
you work on his book
he and I were together for about 20
months most of the time I spent Donna
and a little study in his office
examining the soles of his sneakers he's
a you know very casual guy and he putted
prop his feet up on the desk and and we
would just the start talking with tape
recorder on and essentially what we
arrived at was an extended oral history
Colin Powell has an extraordinarily
retentive mind he's a great storyteller
every once in a while when we were sated
with working on the book he would regale
me with his renditions of Jamaican songs
which had kind of a naughty double
entendre lyric it was this stimulating
experience what do you know about him
that we don't that gives you a certain
view of him during this crisis as
Secretary of State
well I I'm not sure who would not be
aware of this now but my sense is that
were fortunate in and then and Colin
Powell we have an unusual preparation
for the work he's carrying on now this
man from the military standpoint was the
the nation's chief military figure as
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
frequently overlooked is the fact that
he had already been a national security
adviser he was Reagan's man at the NSC
and then he's developed a worldwide
reputation for integrity intelligence
candor so that in building coalitions
this is enormous Lee important I think
we had an extraordinary combination in
Colin Powell and I would say in short
the man I see is resolute but at the
same time reasonable and that's a
comfort we just on a personal level if
somebody can't be in said Joe I'm gonna
go meet comb power I gotta do business
with him what would you tip him off to
do well I I will tell you Brian would I
when I told my wife when I first met
Colin Paul I went down to the Pentagon
the very day
for he retired from 35 years in the
military's joint chairman of the Joint
Chiefs and we were just kind of sizing
each other up for the collaboration and
I went home and my wife said well what
does he like
and I said : Powell is the most
comfortable man in his skin whom I have
ever met and what I would tell somebody
is pretty much expect a direct casual
figure with no guile no side to him so
how did you get to all this where did
you first get interested in being a
writer well I wanted to be a writer ever
since I was a kid
finally I backed into writing I guess I
was for many years chief speechwriter
for governor and later vice president
Nelson Rockefeller did that for a long
time as I say and started out the first
five years I loved it the next three
years I tolerated it the final four
years I hated it had nothing to do with
with my boss it was that I wanted to
write my own books and finally rather
late in life I would say in my 40s I
started writing my own histories and
biographies I counted in the front part
of the book that this would be your
ninth book do we miss any not that I'm
going to admit to yes these you wrote in
94 about Nuremberg in 91 about William
Casey and 98 about Edward Armour Oh in
1979 piercing the Reich the penetration
of Nazi Germany by American secret
agents during World War two how much of
that looked led to what you're doing
here well it led to a sense of
confidence that I could write reasonably
well about intelligence now I did that
book and another book that the adult
with intelligence was Casey William J
Casey who subsequently becomes the
director of Central Intelligence and who
I first had met in talking to him about
Bill Donovan's OSS a Casey you know as
the Brits would say had a pretty good
war casey was was posted in in england
during the latter part of world war ii
and he was responsible for one of the
great triumphs during that period which
was something that british said couldn't
be done and that is we got a number of
teams inside nazi germany and two into
something like sixty german cities so
this would have been a coup for the OSS
and a coup for the Roosevelt
administration of the war what is magic
the u.s. code crackers were working very
hard prior to 1940 in breaking the
Japanese diplomatic code they called it
code purple they finally broke that code
and there there it was broken this by a
team led by a man named Frank
Rowlett Rowlett and his people were now
able in effect to place the President of
the United States on the distribution
list of the Japanese Foreign Office
because we're breaking these messages
they're available in a very in a very
short time they it may be a message from
the Foreign Office in Tokyo to the
American it's excuse me to the japanese
ambassadors in washington we're breaking
that code and these messages go up to
praying to president roosevelt very
quickly and that's what the magic
operation was very important because our
breaking of the Japanese codes were
responsible for our 1942
victory in the Pacific and Midway which
is a turning part of that war and Frank
Rolla is what kind of a guy back then
and where did he operate from Frank
Rowlett was operating out of a former
girls school in the Northern Virginia
suburbs of Washington called arlington
hall he operated with a very small group
of people i can't imagine they made a
great deal of money they worked for the
army as cryptographers but they were
very dedicated and there their
breakthrough was really a significant
advance
for us one of the things that they
enabled us to do by breaking the
Japanese codes we also were able to find
out German intent how did that come
about because the Japanese had an
ambassador posted to Berlin his name was
Oshima Oshima was a rabid pro-nazi
consequently he won the confidence of
odd off Hitler Hitler would bring in
Oshima and say mr. ambassador I'm going
to send you to inspect the Atlantic Wall
I want you to see what I'm erecting to
repeal a Allied invasion of the
continent or he would say to Oshima I'm
going to tell you how many divisions I
have deployed in Norway Denmark in
Belgium most importantly in in France
and then he would say to Oshima upon
these and these are over and rather
critical revelations and I don't want
you to breathe a word of this to anybody
well Oshima did what a good diplomat
does he would report back to Tokyo
virtually verbatim his conversations
with Hitler
through that diplomatic code that we're
breaking and these messages then are
available to the President to the
Secretary of War to the military chiefs
one of the most significant revelations
was when when Hitler tells Oshima I'll
tell you where the Allies are going to
strike they're going to strike up the
pas-de-calais the narrowest part of the
British channel of the English Channel
and he reports this back to Tokyo we
intercept it we now know that Hitler
expects the invasion there why is that
significant because that was our
deception plan that's exactly what we
wanted him to think and we know what's
working
say that that some 400 messages that FDR
could have read from Oshima there was
something like 400 Oshima intercepts per
your general mars year yes general
Marshall said that he was our best
source of information on German
intentions he was our best agent an
unwitting agent albeit and for the
president it was not simply peeking at
the other fellows hand it was like
holding the other fellows hand so the
president's in the Oval Office and
everyday they could bring in these
Oshima messages and did the Japanese
ever find out that the president knew
all the stuff it's really extraordinary
in 1942 after the Battle of Midway a
Chicago Tribune front-page DES story
which practically blew the secret little
issue the Tribune headline read in
effect Navy knew Japanese war plan well
how else would we have known it and the
story is virtually saying we're breaking
the Japanese code astonishingly while
any cabdriver in Chicago could have
drawn that conclusion
the Japanese considered their code
unbreakable they use the same
compromised code to the end of the war
you mentioned the Chicago Tribune and
again I want to try to relate to the
atmosphere we're living in right now
first of all when you read this book
your first thing that comes to mind is
the FDR knew a lot more than the
American people ever knew and I wonder
if you think that our president today
knows a lot more than we'll ever know
about what's going on in the world well
I would think the President does I would
think the intelligence gathering
agencies do because you know it's not
it's almost like a criminal
investigation or manhunt that we're on
now and and and by revealing everything
you know you also tip off your
adversaries as to what you know you dry
up sources you compromised people I
think it has to be that way you point
out that 20 cases of espionage happened
here in the United States from outside
coming in and that at one point there
was 16 of the 20 they had in jail
somewhere but what I'm getting at is
what how much I'm looking at a story of
Willie cold Paws at the NASA how much of
the you know are the enemy coming inside
this country did we have back in World
War 2 surprisingly little the FBI had
rounded up almost all agents operating
with the United States however Hitler
was very unhappy with the job being done
by his intelligence service the other
and pressured Admiral Canaris his
intelligence chief to do something more
dramatic the result was an operation
called pastorius in which eight Germans
who had lived in the United States two
of whom had been US citizens and men who
had gone back to Germany were recruited
to form this team they were put a short
in the United States via submarine in
the summer of 1942 to carry out
espionage one of them decided to rat on
his other comrades thinking this would
make him a hero this and so they were
all quickly rounded up this story is
fairly well known what is far less known
was Roosevelt's attitude towards these
saboteurs
he immediately directs his attorney
General Francis Biddle to organize the
trial outside of the civilian courts
through a military tribunal and he said
to little in effect these are agents of
the enemy they've come ashore in wartime
they're in civilian clothes I don't
think there can be any doubt as to what
their fate must be so he keeps the this
case out of the civilian courts because
the rules of evidence are of restrict
the opportunities for appeal seem to be
endless
a military court which he creates and he
names all the members and then he
directs his attorney general Biddle to
prosecute the case so that within eight
weeks of these saboteurs setting foot in
the United States they have been all
been condemned to death two of them
subsequently
commuted but what I found interesting
was that this Hudson River patricians
amiable genial Franklin Roosevelt was
underneath hard as nails
he expressed his only regret in this
case that these men hadn't suffered the
more ignominious fate of being hanged
rather than being electrocuted more of
our interview with Joseph Persico in
just a moment mr. persico's work on the
development of espionage during the
Roosevelt administration is only one of
nearly 80 stories taken from the past 15
years of booknotes TV interviews found
now in book notes on American character
people politics and conflict in American
history it's available in bookstores and
online and out back to our booknotes
interview with Joseph Persico I
mentioned Willie Cole Paul you right
here on page 387 he had never fit in he
was a bony six-foot - 26 year-old from a
good Greenwich Connecticut family but a
social outcast and a loner what happened
there we got what did he do though what
was that store called paw as you've just
read didn't seem to fit anywhere he had
German ancestry and consequently he was
enamored of what was happening in
Germany and very much impressed by
Hitler's early victories and manages to
get himself thrown out of the US Navy
for being overtly pro-nazi manages
through merchant vessels to get himself
into Europe and he volunteers with
another figure to carry on probably the
last attempt the Nazis made to to land
saboteurs ashore in the United States he
meets one of his former schoolmates who
persuades him that this is madness Col
Paul turns himself in serves a modest
sentence after the war we knew we had
victory and hand down there wasn't quite
this this spirit of vengeance that F
er had expressed earlier but you put I
mean one of the things as interesting is
it he was dropped in the Frenchman's Bay
up there and I assume in Maine yeah he
got back into the country right he
didn't he did make it back to the United
States with a bundle of money he had a
good time with the Fuehrer's dollar
supply but it was useless as an agent I
think the the lack of appropriateness of
this man and the previous team I talked
about as an indication of how weak
German intelligence was is targeted
against the United States who's this
fellow right here
that man is Ernst put C Hamish tingle
that was his nickname put C he had been
a close personal associate of Hitler's
he handled the foreign press for Hitler
he was a pretty good pianist and he was
dubbed Hitler's piano player hunch
Dingle was eventually driven out of a
Hitler circle by more ruthless Nazi
rivals became frightened for his life
went to England the war breaks out and
hunched angle is in turned in a powa
camp he is subsequently sprung by one of
FDR's personal agents John Franklin
Carter who I mentioned earlier and they
bring him to the United States and they
install him in a safe house in
Washington suburbs now Roosevelt is very
interested in how much tangled because
first of all he is half American and he
comes from a pedigreed New England
family and like FDR he went to Harvard
I'm tunnels job is to provide the
president with inside information on the
cast of characters and the Third Reich
and anything else he can provide a value
much of what he provides is more
titillating than elevating he sent
reports the Roosevelt about how Hitler
headaches sent out agents to recover
pornographic paintings that
had done as a penniless artist in Vienna
he he was able to report to the
President on how the Hitler Ava brown
romance had begun he further was able to
tell the president about Hitler's sexual
ambiguity he also was able to deliver
some intelligence or estimations that
were off substance for example he was
the first to insist that Hitler no
matter how bad things got would not
surrender that it would commit suicide
first which is indeed what happened the
president looked forward to these
reports from hunched angle he called
them my Hitler bedtime stories
what in what ended up happening did
[ __ ] well [ __ ]
seemed to lose favor when he gotten done
telling his bedtime stories or when he
had to reveal whatever he knew which
about the Third Reich and he's now a
number of years divorced from that and
because he's kind of a pain in the neck
who expects the United States to provide
him with a piano take care of all of his
dental work he's finally shipped back to
the powa camp in Britain and that is the
end of his spy career also you have
sprinkled in your book some stories that
if it were to happen today they would
keep some cable networks going for about
three months and what I'm getting at is
things like the Eleanor Roosevelt Joseph
life story the personal side of that
where do those ended did the how did the
present did the president know about
those kind of stories well there's an
there's an interesting dichotomy in in
Hoover's relationship with FDR and with
with Eleanor Roosevelt he got along
surprisingly well you have this genial
patrician charming figure on one side
and the dour Hoover on the other but
they cooperated very closely however
Eleanor Roosevelt had made the mistake
once of referring to J Edgar Hoover as
stupid because he was pressing
they background clearance of a White
House staffer who'd been around for
years Hoover was not the kind of figure
who would forget a slight and
consequently when the army came up with
a preposterous report that Eleanor
Roosevelt had been involved in the
sexual tryst with her young protege Joe
lash Hoover kept this information in his
own private files to the day of his
death what was this story though there
was ever proved that they had a
relationship no the army intelligence
people that provided this information to
Hoover had made a small error in their
eavesdropping they had found Eleanor
Roosevelt you know in a hotel with last
visiting but what they produced as proof
of a tryst was young lashes involvement
with it with his girlfriend he was
having an affair with a married woman at
the time who we subsequently married
himself but the the army Mellie military
intelligence people are taping this
they're peeping through through holes in
the wall and somehow it gets mixed up
that it's not lashing this girlfriend
Trudy
but it's slashing Eleanor Roosevelt how
public has the Sumner Welles story been
the one in the Train
it's it's fairly well known what you're
referring to is the fact that Sumner
Welles who was the Undersecretary of
State in the Roosevelt administration
and who was an important figure
he was Roosevelt's man the Secretary of
State was Cordell Hull and Rosa pretty
much circumvented him and and worked
through Sumner Welles who was an old
family friend Welles had made some
sexual advances on trains and part of
his business trips to black Porter's on
these trains who reported him this was
concealed for a long time it was two or
three years before it finally erupted
Roosevelt is under tremendous pressure
from people who fear that
having a man with homosexual tendencies
in such a sensitive position at state we
have to remember we're not talking about
the current world we're talking about
the attitudes of the of the 1940s he's
looked upon as a security threat and
Roosevelt very unhappily eventually
dismisses Sumner wealth what I thought
was interesting was after he asked has
to force Wells out of the State
Department
he considers centering Wells on a
mission to Moscow for him and he's
talked out of that but one can only
imagine what the capabilities of the
NKVD to to blackmail and to lead people
into compromising positions what might
have come of that assignment and how
does William Bullock fit into all this
William Bullock was a a rival of of
Sumner Welles bullet had been FDR's
ambassador to France obviously he has to
come back when France Falls and he is
one who is pressuring the president to
do something about Sumner Welles to get
rid of him Roosevelt is as loyal to
people any very fond of Sumner Welles
and he is a very dependent on Sumner
wealth and after he hears of the tiring
of Sumner Welles by bill bullet in
effect says to bill bullet but Sumner
Welles is doing is wrong but what you
are doing to denigrate another man will
send you down there and he makes this
hellward gesture there's so many stories
as you know in this book you bet in the
back of a legend of where you got a lot
of it
you mentioned the library how much time
did you spend at the Hyde Park library
well I was practically living there for
many months I'd Park was a commute for
me almost it was about an hour and a
half from my home in Albany New York
that was my greatest source I also had
my
results in my research at the National
Archives the Library of Congress the
stories I was telling about the messages
that were intercepted by ambassador
Oshima I managed to track down at the
National Archives I don't think they've
been looked at very much or at all since
that time that was very rewarding for a
researcher one of the things you have
listed is the PS and you have a little
designation so you can tell where
something's come from PSF presidents
secretaries file Roosevelt Library you
have a lot of people mind that file
certain areas things have been mined
rather heavily but there are always
fresh revelations that astonish me for
example there was some suspicion that a
economist by the name of Lachlan Currie
who was a utility infielder for
President Roosevelt took on undertook
many trusted missions there was some
suspicion about his loyalty and I'm
plowing through the archives at Hyde
Park and I find that Lachlan Currie was
the white house man
tracking the development of a secret
explosive RDX somehow Soviet Union finds
out about the development of RDX on
another another occasion he is assigned
to track the development of a new bomber
the b-29 somehow the Soviet Union finds
out about the b-29 these were things
that I discovered that I don't imagine
anybody paid any attention to before so
there are still among these millions of
pages some fresh research nuggets
whatever happen to Lachlan Curie
well Lachlan Curie denied after the war
the that he had ever been a a spy or
that he had ever been a member of the
Communist Party Michael Curry was one of
a number of people who were useful to
the Soviet Union who took the position
at that period that Russia is our ally
why should we hold anything back from
the Soviet Union so a guy like curry may
not have been a spy
in the white house and the most narrow
technical sense but he certainly was a
priceless source of intelligence it's
not often that I would cite a PR insert
in a book but this was the most complete
PR advance work I've ever seen I guess
from Random House that's right publisher
and the reason I cited is because in
spite of reading the book it makes it so
easy I'm gonna go down the list of
things that they point out here because
time goes by very quickly but just give
people just a little nugget of what what
you're talking about here it says you're
among the revelations discussing
Roosevelt's secret war the fair of US
intelligence to anticipate the surprise
Pearl Harbor attack well why why did
they fail because as I have explained to
people at the time or I should excuse me
after the fact that threat of
intelligence running from A to B to C to
Pearl Harbor seems glaringly obvious or
from X to Y to Z but did they have the
entity intelligence information they had
they had the intelligence they had the
information but it came in a flood tide
in in the Roosevelt era you know the
Roosevelt didn't get intelligence
decrypts that had been examined by
analysts and and placed together like
pieces of the jigsaw puzzle he got raw
intelligence you know it's very hard to
sense what's the direction of this
what's it warning us about what is our
antagonist likely to do next also we had
we had nobody on the ground we had no
spies inside to Japan just as apparently
we haven't done very much to penetrate
the inner sanctum of our current
adversaries another item FDR wanted to
bomb Tokyo before Pearl Harbor yeah
that's amazing
Roosevelt was outraged by the behavior
of the Japanese in the war against China
machine gunning civilians in the Street
bombing defenseless cities he considered
a plan this was a year in advance of
Pearl Harbor whereby the United States
would give b-17 bombers to the Chinese
and trained Chinese pilots to fly them
against Tokyo he was told that would
take too long to train
pilots so the backup position was we
would give the bombers to China we would
have American pilots resigned from the
Air Force and volunteer to fly them so
we would have American pilots flying
American planes a year before Pearl
Harbor against Tokyo he was advised by
cooler heads that this would be an
outright provocation and could only lead
to war the British fed FDR phony
intelligence to draw the United States
into the war well Winston Churchill was
very eager to have the United States
join the war against Hitler and
consequently British agents were to
provide intelligence that would help
this happen
they told Roosevelt about the fact that
the Germans had taken a map cut Latin
America into six future Nazi vassal
states that that a Bolivian pro US
government was going to be toppled by
the Nazis that we had 6,000 Brazilian
troops
excuse me 6,000 German troops in Brazil
Roosevelt used some of this information
in his speeches and in his fireside
chats it was all fabricated but by the
British to help encourage the United
States to enter the war
FDR's yielding to Churchill led to the
theft of the a-bomb yeah a curious tale
in the beginning the United States and
Britain were full partners in developing
an atomic weapon but as time went on and
the United States launched the Manhattan
Project was putting millions of dollars
into this creating the facility at Los
Alamos we became the dominant partner
and started cutting the British out of
what was happening
for security reasons Churchill comes to
the United States at one point sees
Roosevelt at Hyde Park he's furious he
accuses Roosevelt of reneging so a
compromise is reached
the British will not beginning
information on the a-bomb imported in to
Britain but we will allow a small team
of British physicists mathematicians and
other scientists to work at Los Alamos
one of them turns out to be Klaus Fuchs
so as we
Luke steals majors secrets of the bomb
gives it this information to his Soviet
controllers he is it at los alamos
because of a deal cut between Franklin
Roosevelt and Winston Churchill what
happens to Klaus Fuchs Fuchs is finally
unmasked several years after the war in
1950 he was sentenced I think of 14 year
prison term eventually upon his release
he continued his work in East Germany
how did he get into this in the first
place
well he Klaus Fuchs had been a young
avid communist in his native Germany
things got very tough for communists in
Germany as the Nazis came to power so he
fled to a Great Britain and eventually
became a British citizen back to the PR
sheet here which by the way did you
write this I made some suggestions
because you know sometimes the authors
don't and they're always surprised by
what's in there a leaked FDR plan led
Hitler to declare war on the United
States you know this is frequently
overlooked Brian that the United States
did not declare war on Germany we
declared war only on Japan on December
8th 1941 why did Hitler do something
seemingly so rash there was a leak of an
important document called rainbow 5 a
contingency plan that Roosevelt had
called for what would we need should we
go to war against Germany by 1943 how
many divisions how many ships
how many aircraft how much fuel etc
Chicago Tribune gets a hold of the
secret plan and front pages it does not
play it as a contingency plan the
Tribune plays it as a war plan and the
headline says FDR 5 million troops
against Germany by 43 and when Hitler
declares war on the United States four
days after Pearl Harbor he virtually
quotes this he says President Roosevelt
intends to make war against us by 1943
so in declaring
war against the united states he doesn't
view it as being rash he views as
anticipating the inevitable and getting
the draw on the US the relationship
between FDR and Joseph Stalin well the
the president recognized that Stalin was
taking eighty percent of the casualties
during World War two and inflicting
eighty percent of the casualties on the
Germans so he was very very eager to
cultivate and placate Joe Stalin would
bend over backwards I'll give one
example there is the long-standing
controversy about the katene Forrest who
murdered nine thousand poles in the
katene forest the Germans claimed the
Soviet Union did it the Soviet Union
claimed that it happened when the
Germans occupied this territory this
story was rather controversial for a
half a century interestingly enough
Roosevelt and Churchill knew from day
one that these murders of the poles had
been done by Soviet Union on Joseph
Stalin's orders they didn't say anything
again because they did not want to
alienate Stalin who could conceivably
make a separate peace with Germany then
we would have been left with the bulk of
the fighting of the bulk of the
casualties page 273 this seemed to be a
one of those sentences that people who
don't like FDR probably use when they're
talking about him I think this is a
quote I think if I give Stalin
everything I possibly can and ask for
nothing from him in return noblesse
oblige he won't try to annex anything
and will work with me for a world of
democracy and peace where does that come
from it comes out of Franklin
Roosevelt's character which is a
reliance on
you know an almost overwhelming charm
Roosevelt could chair him almost anybody
and he thought that he could charm Joe
Stalin by being utter utterly respectful
and admiring and not questioning
anything that Stalin did underrating the
hard pragmatism of a Joe Stalin did that
hurt us in the negotiations well it hurt
us to the extent that for example the
story I just told about the cartoon for
us that we are not letting the American
people know the that the monstrousness
of Stalin is not all that different from
that of about off Hitler but in in the
end I I don't accept the charge that the
Roosevelt gave the store away at Yalta
which is a common conclusion of many who
discussed this era he was too forgiving
and too accommodating to Stalin I but I
don't think he he gave anything away
that created our post-war confrontation
with so anything about his relationship
with Winston Churchill that you hadn't
known in the past it was a relationship
that that started poorly Franklin
Roosevelt had a tremendous ego as a
young assistant secretary of the Navy he
had visited Britain and he had come away
with a very poor opinion of Winston
Churchill he said that Winston Churchill
had not shown any any respect for him a
coffee Winston Churchill a stinker
subsequently when pearl harbors attacked
Churchill calls him and says we're all
in the same boat now they pretty much
behaved that way although we have two
men both with giant egos and and and
they do collide occasionally because
Britons of objectives are not the United
States objectives and this is clearest
and in Churchill's determination to win
this war at least in part to be able to
restore
the British Empire much of which has
been taken away by the Japanese and sure
and Roosevelt wants to go in the
opposite direction he wants this war to
serve the human end of allowing
countries to develop their their own
independence their own freedom so there
is a real collision you say that
President Kennedy's father Joseph
Kennedy called him at one point quote he
was angry call him a crippled sob
remember where that quote came from and
why did he calling that Joe Kennedy had
a son Joe Kennedy jr. the elder brother
of the future President Roosevelt was
very insistent that a certain secret
operation take place in which an
aircraft would be loaded with high
explosives pilot and the copilot would
head it towards a target v1 and v2 was
the German secret weapon launching sites
the pilots would bail out and a guide
plane would would in effect lead this
flying bomb towards the target through
radio remote control
Churchill opposed this Churchill was
afraid that the Nazis would retaliate
against London and Roosevelt took the
position we know they're developing
these secret weapons they're gonna
strike London anyway so this plan
aphrodite went forward and on the first
mission Joe Kennedy and his pilot take
off with this explosives load the
aircraft it explodes mysteriously both
men are killed Joe Kennedy senior who at
one point had been Roosevelt's
ambassador to Great Britain runs into
Harry Truman in an event Truman is then
Roosevelt's vice presidential candidate
in the 1944 election and Joe Kennedy
says to Harry Truman Harry what are you
doing working for that crippled SOB who
killed my son Joe
there's a woman that is always around
FDR in your book someone named Margaret
sook Lee Daisy Suckley who was she and
where did you get the information about
her
Daisy Suckley was a distant cousin of
Roosevelt she's in the middle in this
picture take a little closer look
yes and Daisy Suckley was a person who
Roosevelt would confide in things that
he would not tell to anybody else he
felt perfectly comfortable because she
adored him he knew he had her absolute
trust so he told her things that for
example would have very much surprised
other members of the Roosevelt team one
of which was the state of FDR's health
from a last year at least of FDR's life
he was a dying man he had been examined
that the Bethesda Naval Center by
cardiologist they realized he had
astronomic blood pressure that he was
suffering from hardened hardening of
their arteries amazingly Roosevelt never
asked a question he never asked what was
the result of these examinations what
had they found a cardiologist is
assigned to him in the White House who
checks him out daily he Joshes with the
cardiologist gossips with him never asks
about his condition so one would have
the sense that he doesn't know what's
happening or doesn't want to know but he
on one occasion in one of these private
sessions with his confidant and distant
cousin Daisy Suckley
he says in effect I am I am very sick
much sicker than I have been told and if
I am sick enough I will not run for
another term
I must be convinced that I can complete
another term he's talking about a fourth
term and as we know he he's right on one
count he runs again he's wrong and
another count he dies only four months
into his fourth term
unfortunately no fortunately I have
about a hundred more questions for it
but unfortunately it's time is up our
guest has been Joseph Persico his book
is called Roosevelt's secret war thank
you very much for joining us thank you
for having me Brian